yeah hello welcome to this video a
little bit of a late start here Knight
f3 that's uncommon huh interesting stuff
hmm yeah probably just develop here
Bishop c5 the e4 pawn is something that
could become a problem now it tries to
attack it huh yeah this looks like
fairly yeah normal is wrong it's wrong
word but in the Sicilian Russell emo you
have sometimes positions that look it
looks similar how to do this yeah it's
not so easy am queen to Quincy to
let's see if I can disturb him there a
little bit yeah I'm starting to take and
take on you for so i need to lend some
additional protection to the you for
porn okay whoa isn't that somewhat
dangerous him let's see i'm as usual
playing in primitive fashion queen g5
age 5 h to mate so what seems like he
wants to block this with night h3 so
queen g5 yes let's get the Queen near
this also i mean III is also something
that has to be taken into account
sometimes or taking 1 f 2 actually
okay take it on f 2 is probably not i'm
especially convincing queen age 69 h3a
night have to look take screen g3
probably just a queen move I don't think
this is so so great so I'll go with this
and I have 95 I mean if everything else
fails I have that but it's not so so
great right and it's that some way to to
fight fight my way through here night if
I if I that it's that doesn't do that
much you can just come back and I don't
want to play a lame move like oxy aid
there's some way to get more pieces into
the game I can't I go I don't exceed
spend too much time you already tried to
figure out stuff yeah I'm okay if I
would have played 95 you just would have
gone back okay yeah this is actually
something that i don't mind 94 looks
annoying let's do this threatening 92
yeah it's hard to see him not taking
this always locally when the player will
move its 97
check I notice you really want to I
don't get it maybe you just overlook
that
night XD 3 mate is a pretty big threat
white resides yeah so I should have just
played rook c8 a lot quicker yeah very
unconventional move or even white but
the position he is not dead yeah that
that exotic sometimes see stuff like
that when the Russell Nemeth cars
reversed yeah at age five it just
because as king as somewhat deserted so
felt that this is an interesting idea
and it gets dangerous this is dangerous
without any any doubt it's already
computed already gives black a big
advantage here it wants to play 93 now
then i can i can take here this is not
bearable and he also 25 is strong yeah
not a good position okay Queen g5 this
Queen age six and now you have the rook
ac8 is the best move I have to spend
that move okay so it took a long time
but it was it was right default I don't
think that why can survive this this is
minus minus 2.4 inch and rising yeah
this this may be but i can check play it
chinese move this is important then
white will get get mate it or lose the
house check you can do this check but
it's a queen to check now what is
falling apart completely okay thanks for
watching